to the first blind date of my life  alright I'll choose that it's not a  serial killer  Sarah hi are you Nick yes I'm nervous  but like I've never done buying date  before so me either  unlike the goodie girl I've never done a  drug and you oh yeah I love them oh my  god this conversation just took a really  interesting turn there's the first blind  dates  whoo I think sometimes people swipe past  the best thing out there you like it big  oh my god you're a headache  I was getting the feeling that you  weren't that into me this is called  culture clash I hate this [ __ ]  I don't want to be some version of me  that other people want me to be and  definitely want a family and create a  life with someone else find the right  person I'm one of like following so when  do we do this again  [Music]  you  [Music]  you